he's back
[Music]
[Applause]
and that is
[Music]
all right and that is some very awkward
intro Eastern music right there and
that's intro that's Easter because it's
Easter think about it dude I can't look
up on Easter up to you this here if I
even on Easter now when I hear even
somebody crack an egg in the morning you
hear them crack that egg and you think
all men would that's Jesus brother and
then what is that is that an omelet what
is that that's Jesus is that a crepe
that's Jesus crepes
because you get that you just in your
brain in my brain I get that that
feeling that yes soos is in the air baby
because Jesus look he's that beautiful
burglar and he'll break right into your
heart if you let him and he can be
looked different people have different
Jesus's in their life you could have a
different you know your Jesus may have a
different name and different shape you
know your Jesus made am you know he may
have a damn dreamcatcher around his neck
and he may have a couple tattoos on his
arm you know he may be in a full-body
cast or he may have a knee brace on
because he's been playing basketball on
his lunch break and he hurt himself a
little bit but however he is he could
Brett he could break right into your
heart and that's kind of that's how it
goes on Easter and that's what that
music right there that is called the
stories time tells more than family
that's what that little ditty is and
honestly I thought the music was pretty
bad I thought I was getting it I thought
it was gonna be better but welcome to uh
this past weekend thank you guys man I'm
done here in a bet on rule Shh I'm gonna
make sure this cameras on I'm then here
in Baton Rouge Louisiana at my brother's
house and just got done doing a fort
with the children
and in that fort man you remember when
you were young that fort was everything
man we building a fort you got to stay
over tonight we building a dam for and
your buddy would be like huh and you
were like [ __ ] you buddy
we building a fort everybody I knew was
a general contractor when its fourth
time every you could tie anything into a
40 you tie a lamp in you tied a sheet to
a lamp make it tall make your tall make
a tall dog if you had like a little
poodle make him stand there in the
corner and toss sheet around his neck
he's got to hold a corner everybody's
got to hold a corner and then you got
then you had your little maybe you'd
have a um you know a plant pot and you
put the one corner of the sheet under
that and then another then you get
another sheet of blanket everything in
the house goes into making the fort and
then you get up in that bastard and you
all lonely and I'm like damn man this is
this is probably what it's like one day
if you don't get married and don't have
any uh you know don't have any family
but anyhow um happy Easter to you and I
hope it was a beautiful day I'm down
here my brothers in the living room down
here in Baton Rouge and then we had a
nice time watching the children her
children was all out here and one of the
children - I ain't even brushing their
teeth very much and so he law he already
lost a couple damn teeth so you know but
that's the Lord brother and the Lord
will let you into his into his heart
even if you have no teeth think about
that that's what you got to think man
that faith that welcoming that welcome
and feel of faith that long arm of faith
will open the door
Frieden the toothless because most of us
will let almost anybody in the house
that looks thirsty but if they don't
have that grill they don't have at least
a couple of cheek lettuce in their mouth
bruh then we shut it down
for them you know and this there's just
something about that grill that really
that's that uh it's a it's almost like a
handshake in your mouth with people if
somebody have that grill they have that
first element of introduction of
comfortable introduction but you know
that's when you know that Jesus got a
big old heart because he even loved the
toothless what's what's up what's up
what's up what's up I'm down here and in
Louisiana I came down here I went over
to Dustin Poirier and I saw the strap
dude it was cool you know it's cool to
go see that belt and he's got that real
that piece you know and and then I spent
the rest of the time with family and
friends um my stepmom like I used to
live with a family when I was growing up
and the mom kind of bit the dust the
other day she I think was jacked up on a
couple of quaaludes or something and she
bit the dust at the party at the Easter
party and she had to hit the hospital
but she's all good she came back and
still down a couple cupcakes and uh and
uh and a ginger ale so I mean you know
we in business son and what else man I
hung out here went to church this
morning dude it was cold and one thing I
realize about myself is I'm I'm down for
that I'm D uh you know I'm D F TL I'm
down for the Lord but it was really cold
in there and uh I was like you know I
don't know if I could stay in here I
like I like my god I like a room
temperature God I think you know I like
a room temperature higher power I like
my higher power at room temperature and
it was real cold in there I said and
it's gonna be you know I think God and
God knows I want I want that room
temperature deity I want that room
temperature deity so but we had a good
time and we just did Easter stuff too
the kid that had a jumpy house for the
children and somebody urinated in there
and that's always usually a buzzkill but
down here in south Louisiana dude that
just means you got to jump around if
that's what the kid said and you know
did when they saying you got to jump
around the urine in the jumpy house
that's some real I mean those that's
some real children right there because
you get that much urine airborne in that
jumpy house and you know it that I man
thing is turning into a damn that's like
a swingers thing you know and I got
stuck at this swingers deal one time and
they had a bunch of people you know they
took the light bulb out of the elevator
at nighttime at this hotel and they were
all in there touching each other and I
don't even know Jesus but I took the
stairs the next morning for the
breakfast bar that's for sure what else
man what's going on not much done you're
just very peaceful peaceful time down
here Easter weekend
you know a lot of joy in the air you see
a lot of people it's almost like that
little it's like that baby Christmas and
you got that rabbit and you got diabetes
everybody trying to sneak a snicker and
that's how it always has been when I was
young man you get a little bit of chop
butter you get you know we just have
this dude in our neighborhood named big
Roy and he was um I mean he was
allegedly I'm you know I I'm sexual you
know homeowner they called him Easter
call him homeowners and he's beautiful
fella beautiful hair I remember that I
mean damn he had he had about four feet
of hair just stacked in a one foot on
his head and he almost his hair was just
bat it's almost like he could play a um
a flute a flute like a snake flute you
ever seen those snake flutes on the
Internet where the guy plays it and they
have a snake well he could do he could
play a flute and his hair would just
kind of tighten itself up and really
just kind of hold on to each other his
hair was like it was like a dam just
gangbanged up there and all the
follicles were just wrapped up in each
other's arms
who knows what they were doing you know
hair [ __ ] but um but anyway he what
am I talking about but anyway I think he
was uh he was I remember one time he got
some it was Easter and he got some eggs
that had this saw a little bit of creme
in them and creme is the kind of stuff
mine is something they it's kind of
perverted I think it's supposed to I
don't know what it is hell but they hide
it it's kind of like a sweet juice that
they hide inside of things you know you
might get a UH a doughnut have a little
bit of creme in it you might get a
little wah he got him these Cadbury eggs
he saw British eggs and these [ __ ]
was real royal looking they wrapped him
in like this royal foil and it looked
like I mean it looked like damn you know
Winston Churchill himself [ __ ] that
you know like like Winston Churchill
Hill chicken had hatched this [ __ ] this
was a beautiful egg it was wrapped in
like a delicate fall and you got that
egg and you cracked that thing open when
you bit into it it had this creme that
would I mean drip out of your damn mouth
bra so if he wasn't if you wasn't trying
to meet a man but if you had one of them
eggs boy you could that was easy you
were suddenly men were trying to meet
you because that Krim would leak out of
side of your mouth you know like you
know like that creme was just up to no
good and and it wanted to just party and
you were trying to keep it inside of
your face in that creme that creme
really wanted to party but I remember
that and I remember watching him Edel
and he was a little older than me and he
got a sack of them for Easter one year
he got about maybe seven and he's these
CAD berries these these little British
chocolate just hitters man I mean just
look like nut it look like a damn like a
big nut off a dam like a dam gay dolphin
or something and being Roy just made me
watch him eat all six up and I'm like
damn Ronald
[ __ ] I don't know what's going on but I
didn't uh you know I didn't masturbate
or anything like that I just you know
went on about the rest of my day it was
just Easter so but anyway um yeah that's
it man that's it that's that's really
what's going on and where'd we leave off
the last episode I was talking a little
bit about I don't want to get in that
talked about how you know the escort
thing and Vegas I don't want to get it I
don't want to not get into it I'll get
into it at a different time because I'm
here you know I'm it's Easter and today
I want to talk about uh I don't know
what I want to talk about what's been
going on I got well I mean we know as
always that this episode is brought to
you by great block pizza you know that
and that's at 1811 Pico Boulevard in Los
Angeles on the way to the beach if
you're not sure what's in your mouth and
maybe you should do uh do a little bit
of check you know run a cheese check run
a crust bus to see what kind of things
are milling around in and outside of
your offices because I'll tell you it is
if you find cheese when you cheese check
you find crust when you crust bust then
you know you might have gray block pizza
get that hitter and we had a couple of
people that called in actually with gray
block ads because you guys wanted to try
some of them so let's hear one right
here just this episode this podcast is
brought to you by rocky by gray block
pizza it's like you ever you ever been
down down at the beach thinking like hey
I think that it's pretty good time for
some pizza was gray blocks right there
by the beach and yeah they got hitter
and pepperoni and [ __ ] like oceans where
stories podcast ya episode 692 brought
you by the pizza from gray block say
it's but if you just bring your towel
sunscreens pretty hot in California
there you go and that's one of Ella sent
that in and we'll play one more that
came in this is just a funny thing
couple people hit him onto the onto the
hotline which is always ninety five six
six four nine five zero three let's hit
get that extra gray block this is Ricky
and this is my read for the great block
pizza oh sweet Ricky and you could hear
he got a little bit of that creme on his
voice baby you know what I'm saying he
got that uh that diabetic drip that
little that sucked that little sugar
squirt coming off the edge of them and
they're sweet Ricky amor brother gang
gang this episode is brought to you by
great block pizza and sunny Santa Monica
Pico Boulevard right across the street
from SMC that Santa Monica College if
you're in school
come take a break and get some pizza or
you can pretend to go to school and
instead come to gray block pizza and get
that Pizza education either way with or
without school come get that Hitler
sweet Ricky coming in dripping right in
your ears man right out of his mouth
with that sugar creme right there thank
you guys for sending those in and I
appreciate it
what L I'm just trying to think what
else is going on you know I had a nice
time at church I get nervous sometimes
when I go to church I don't go armed
often you know sometimes once in a while
I'll go in LA I mean I do go to you know
a lot of 12-step meetings and for me
that is a little bit more of or that's
not my higher power but it's where I'm
through 12-step I'm more easy to access
my higher power but in church sometimes
this songs people will start singing and
I'm one of sometimes I want to raise my
hands up like and really feel the Lord
because you can do that reach baby two
arms up you know like somebody it
basically I can football somebody just
scored a touchdown you put two arms up
and
turn the hands forward and that's baby
that's just letting the Lord know hey
stop right here because I need you you
know and I sometimes when I cause I like
the songs I like the music but they got
the they got nine these days a lot of
churches they got that nine-piece band
up there you know they got a nine piece
with two side items and they got the
drummer and he's in like this damn
aquarii I'm like what the [ __ ] did he do
you know you could go up and throw some
fish food at him they throw it every
couple hours somebody would come out and
shake a sardine and he'll jump in the
air and they'd sell tickets to that but
he they got him in this damn cage I
don't know some of it's just too crazy
some of them is I wish that Church they
had a little bit more just that man with
the guitar that's simple just one fell
up there with a friend you know with a
dirt with her with a bruised soul and a
lot on his mind
because I wonder if you could feel that
connection a little bit more if you had
somebody come in and play a song that
really just spoke their troubles or
their struggles I wonder if people could
relate in that sense more because that's
what the Lord is the Lord is that big
aunt 'men do it if you struggling boy
you get it you reach up to the sky and
you get a scoop of the Lord and put that
right in your heart and that'll usually
help but sometimes when I'm in those
when I'm in the when I'm in church I
want to sing and put my hands up but I
don't I get scared and then I just kind
of sometimes I'll put them right on my
chest and just kind of just that's about
it just but not any higher I will go
about my shoulders you know but because
there's something that feels real like
religious when you put your hands up in
the air feels real real religious to me
and when you keep them down like
shoulders are under it feels like
secretly religious you know but what
else I don't know man I you know I'll
tell you this I had an opportunity to do
a television
project somebody offered me a TV project
cuz people are always sending me
messages a man when you're gonna do a
Netflix special when you're gonna do
this when you're gonna do that and I
think about some of it but some of it I
don't know what I want to do and I don't
want to hurry up and make a choice or
choose something that I don't know well
I'm not sure you know and sometimes
honestly I have like a chip on my
shoulder against Hollywood you know I
don't want to do sometimes stuff they
want me to do or I don't want to you
know I don't I don't know I don't feel
like they I feel like there's more power
and owning your own stuff and doing your
own thing I don't want somebody to own
me that's part of it you know I really
don't want somebody to own me you know
I've talked about this before they talk
about you know they had that guy from
Boston Cosby Bill Cosby Show and not the
the sexual abuser they had that other
man Winston or whatever his name was and
he did the arm he was sound Sonya's
husband and somebody called a picture of
him like six months ago doing groceries
doing produce and everything over there
stacking yams at the at a Trader Joe's
and they made fun of him and stuff but I
was thinking why this guy's it was a
television star you know this guy was on
probably 50 episodes of that shove Cosby
Show and I was growing up and went stand
out here [ __ ] checking fresh peaches
but at the same time his show still on
somewhere like it just made me I don't
like ownership I it makes me
uncomfortable so I think you know I
turned down this opportunity that I had
because I'm just not sure and I don't
want to you know if I do something I
want to do something that I want to do
you know and I could be wrong I mean I
could have you know I could have messed
up and but but I don't know I was just
trying to trust my instincts and some of
it's hard to know what your instincts
are that's hard for
sometimes it's hard to know sometimes
what your instincts are but yeah anyway
it made me think that somebody owned
that Cosby got somebody owned him I
don't want that for me and I may have to
have it at some point but I'm gonna be
Sola I'm gonna try and be selective
about it or I don't know but and as far
as Netflix special goes we might do one
sometime we'll see part of me thinks
about just taping some stuff and just
putting the clips on the YouTube that
way I still own my stuff you know I
still own my content I still own my
stories and my in my world that way one
day my children you know if I have
children or my dog if I have a dog will
get will they'll still own that you know
it'll be our it'll be my own stuff
I don't know I'm just I don't know man
I've always had us I've always felt
uncomfortable about somebody I don't
like doing stuff that I like to do my
own thing you know I like to do my own
thing and sometimes it's good because
you know it keeps me kind of self
motivated but sometimes it makes it
tough for me to work with others you
know it sometimes I think I've talked
about this a little bit I think the
reason why I like doing my own thing is
or I don't like doing working with
others I don't know if it's that I don't
like to share I don't think that's it I
think I don't know I for one of this
used to have doing things on my own
and so it must be a trust thing at some
at some level inside of myself I don't
want to trust I know if I do things
myself at least whether they go well or
go poorly at least I didn't have to like
enter into like a trusting agreement
with somebody else you know at least
then it's only me I can only help myself
I can only hurt myself but I don't have
to worry about letting somebody else
you know uh I don't worry about
something letting somebody else
potentially hurt me if I so then I might
lose out on the opportunity for somebody
to help me but as long as somebody can't
hurt me I'm it's like I'm willing to
take that that chance so if I do things
myself then then somebody might not have
the opportunity to help me because I'm
not going to partner up with them but
they're not going to have the
opportunity to hurt me or to take
advantage of me either I think anyway I
don't know kind of thinking out loud
yeah it's nice to see my sibling my
niece isn't everything now real nice you
know I got I mean I'm really blessed to
have just healthy children in our family
you know when I see these kids and I see
you know have five nieces and nephews
and today they're playing and they you
know even they're jumping around the
piss and the in you know blow house or
whatever it's called the jump house and
we never got a jump house dude I
remember we used to when it somebody
would do a ditch fire a lot of times in
our street people would do ditch fires
and we play we played this game called
dirty bandits where you would we put
water on our bodies and jump through the
dark smoked a bunch until we were just
totally like just these dark creatures
kind of and uh and it was funny you just
try to see if he could get smut you know
get the smoke all over your body and
that [ __ ] but it would get in like the
crevices of your neck and behind your
ears and it was you know you had that
very it looked off often look like you
crawled up from literally Middle Earth
when we got home a mom would beat the
[ __ ] out of us and I don't blame her you
know you roll into a house with that
much smoke on you and smoke is really I
mean if devil if fire is is the devil's
the devil's breath
then smoke is just must just be the
remnants of his of his ideas so you roll
them with that you know that smokey the
seasoning basically just all covered in
smoke dirt and you tell your mom we've
been playing dirty bandits and she would
beat the [ __ ] out of it I mean she would
this back when you could beat you beat
the [ __ ] you know beat your kids ass and
still love them now it's like people are
kind of choosing one of the other when I
was young
you got your ass beat but you were still
loved and dearly loved too man and that
was a different time what else I went to
eat well my you know this family I lived
with a nice coma to eat with them and it
was nice man we had a good time you know
I realized a lot just like I don't know
I've been home in a bit and things
change you know people get older you
know one of my nieces is like older now
and she's talking about like drama at
school and the last time I saw her she
was talking about like cut you know
different color pencils and uh and yeah
like one of like like you know someone
in my life can't hear as well as they
used to or somebody can't they're a
little more slower or they're a little I
don't know it's just weird how things
you know how life changes it starts to
get a little spooky you're like damn
life is uh life still it life's just
going life's just going man
it's got that wildness to it it's really
a stray uh it's really a stray animal
isn't it and what do we even know about
it sometimes is a life is almost like
Bigfoot it's like we can only we only
have a couple of kind of ideas of it or
or images or grasp time the movement of
time it's so it's so mysterious and
we're out here just piggybacking on to
it for just a moment
just a moment but anyway I'm not going
to go into a deep episode today but
because I have I have a see stir man I
got to go to sleep I start I got to edit
this thing and get it together but I do
want to say that um well there's a
couple things we'll go into a couple
calls I got to tell you a couple other
things though if your crotch is really
wild and getting you know you got to do
spring cleaning and some people they'll
do their sideburns that they get a q-tip
or borrow a q-tip or a piece of cotton
and like a popsicle stick from the
neighbor or something and they'll clean
out their ears I'll clean up that back
that back shaft behind their ears or
whatever I don't run a hot rag up
through day you know through it a crack
but what I'm talking about is his
manscaped and support for this past
weekend comes from manscaped who is
number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for manscaping with the
right tool for the right job
some people think your crotch is gonna
take care of itself
well that's absolutely that's absolutely
dumb brother you know nobody had that
self taking care of crotch unless they
were in a fire some so you need to you
need to tend to the hair around your
wiener and sack in air and you know ball
area what I'm saying is that manscaped
can help if you've ever nicked your nuts
with a little you know some people like
to use a regular razor or maybe a
scalpel to try to trim the hair around
their nuts those people are those people
are not wise you know they would not be
the type of people that would give gifts
to a baby in a crib in the desert and
follow the North Star because those
would be not wise people but with
manscaped things are different manscaped
offers the lawnmower 2.0 which features
quiet stroke technology which we've all
used if we've ever tried to touch
ourselves you know when we were young
and somebody was sleeping ah you know on
the bed next to us or or you were in
like one of those little detention
centers at school when you had that
little cubicle you're trying to quietly
be by yourself and also be sexy
the lawnmower 2.0 features quiet stroke
technology it's terrifying to trim your
balls when the trimmer sounds like a
chainsaw but the lawnmower 2.0 is so
quiet it gives you confidence to turn
the most sensitive areas it's perfect
for travel it's small so it fits in your
travel bag it has a convenient USB
charger and it's TSA approved if the
lady at TSA say what is that you say
that's that manscape or baby because i
am going to dandy up minuttes
it features replaceable trimmer blades
that help you trimmer that helps your
trimmer stay hygienic and prevents
manscaping accidents get 20% off and
free shipping with the code Theo
th EO at man scaped comm again get 20%
off free shipping and a travel bag with
the code th EO at manscaped
dot-com that's 20% off with free
shipping in a travel bag at manscape
calm and use code th e oh let's get into
a couple of calls here that have come in
I appreciate you guys hitting the
hotline as always nine eighty five six
six four nine five zero three here we go
hey Ron this is Dana think we're falling
amen you answered my phone call thank
you for calling brother I appreciate you
calling I couldn't hear your name
because you fast you talk quit but I'm
glad you talked quick man because it
keeps my ears you know you really
challenging my ears
some people they slow talking my ears
[ __ ] they barely have to do anything
so I appreciate you engaging on word
podcast so move to Portland and you wish
like okay you we had you on the podcast
don't move to Portland I hear what
you're saying okay homework
it has a new experience for me then
and all on the podcast I'll move to
Portland and you wished the life has a
new experience for me then and it really
has
I think then I've gotten my license back
I just got back into school I'm throwing
a fundraiser your day before my birthday
I got a lot of good things going on I
just want to thank you man you wish that
into the world for me and is truly
effort
oh man will appreciate the coal man
thank yourself you know thank yourself
as the sweet of you and you're welcome
but thank yourself you know you get out
there and uh man ah but you know is it
yes what we do for ourselves you know
and in the end really it's what we do
for others that makes us feel good but
man when you say yeah you're doing a
little fundraiser before your birthday
what a gift what a gift when your
birthday to give something to somebody
else do something special for someone
else I love it man you know I'm
realizing more and more that the that
even as funny as we get disconnected as
as humans get disconnected how the value
of human connection is so there's
nothing like it there's nothing like
when you connect with somebody else you
know it's funny I was at a meeting this
weekend I went to a 12-step meeting him
and uh talked about this but a woman you
know there was somebody talking about
they couldn't somebody was upset because
they I think I have to keep whatever how
they talked about in there in there so I
I can't share that but well I'll get
back into our calls and thank you for
the call let's hit this one here we go
ninety five six six four nine five zero
three vo dang this is Josh from Virginia
colin jost from Virginia in Virginia man
if you want to do some tobacco and
[ __ ] being a Civil War Reenactment
that's the place to go if you want to
put a plug of that you know that ginger
if you want to put a plug of that
gingersnap in your lip you know and you
want to put a plug at that [ __ ] that
leafy hooker bra that thing that'll get
you hooked you know that's the sent us
Mother Nature Cinnabon brother
that's the Cinnabon of vegetables
tobacco leaf you put a plug a tad up in
your lip and get jacked out you can do
that over in Virginia you'll see a dam
but you'll see a four you'll see a four
year old with a little wood you know
lighten up an American spirit and lying
about it oh we're a longtime podcast
listener I have they had a question for
you long-distance relationships what's
your advice on on you know just making
that work making that making that the
best best of the situation I'm in the
long-distance relationship things are
going well I think things could
definitely always do better okay that
long-distance relationship man uh dude
I'll cheat him when I'm in the longest
relationship I cheat so but I'm also
very loving on the phone I'm very loving
I just I don't know why I do that you
know to be honest not my whole life I've
always done that I've always anytime
I've been in a long relationship I lied
and I cheated and I'm not proud of it
[Music]
and I know I had a choice like I know I
had a choice but in some weird way I
know this is gonna sound I'm not trying
to let myself off the hook but I don't
know if I had a choice sometimes like I
needed I needed to I needed some type of
attention not even really affection or
sexual affection but I needed attention
I needed and he constantly you know a
lot of me knowing I'm okay came from
other people and still does a lot of
times and I needed somebody I needed a
you know I needed to be able to
you know engage with someone or us to
know that I was all right to know that I
was okay they let me know that by they
engaged with me if they didn't engage
with me if they were you know if I'm
just sitting on the phone being sad
because somebody else isn't around you
know the only way I knew I was going to
be you know I had to had to know and
also I feel this need like sometimes I
realized that like some of the reasons
why I think I would do that a lot of
times is because if a woman was
interested in me I felt a responsibility
to be interested in them like I felt
like like if I didn't like somebody who
liked me then I was letting them down
because I think so often in my growing
up I liked girls and they didn't like me
and I took it personally for some reason
you know and so I felt like personally
those girls were letting me down and so
then when I got a little bit older and
girls would like me I would feel like a
full man if I don't return this favor
reciprocate this in some way even if
it's just physically then I'm letting
them down and I know how that feels and
I don't want to do that and I know
that's kind of [ __ ] up thinking I'm
not even but yes sometimes I was like oh
man sometimes I would hook up with and
it would have to be a girl that I was
attracted to like what if someone are
somewhat you know there have to be some
level of connection but it would be like
man if I don't do if I don't then I'm I
just didn't want to hurt anybody's
feelings sometimes
that's crazy I didn't want to hurt hurt
a woman's feelings so I would engage
with him you know and do sexual
engagement of some type touching or
caressing or something or just [ __ ] just
watch somebody eat a damn cat berry egg
and get that British drip bra get that
sweet drip drop
but long-distance relationships do
usually I mean it's a lot of times you
would listen to sad you'd listen to
songs that remind you of them and cry
you know you would talk on the phone all
the time do back in the day think about
you wouldn't see somebody for months six
months maybe nine months you writing
them letters you get over there and
[ __ ] they don't even live there
anymore and it's just a couple of new
neighbors that have been reading all the
letters you wrote them and they're like
damn you sound like a real [ __ ] buddy
it's just you know times are so
different now we have so much connection
it's like but it's not like really a
deep connection we have so much like
voice and video ability that you can
always be kind of right there with
somebody in a lot of ways you know you
don't really get a chance to miss
someone like you used to and when I was
young you wouldn't miss somebody man you
wouldn't because there wasn't so much
constant connection man if you saw
somebody walk by you might [ __ ] never
see him again
or if you you know like there was no way
to just reach out and touch everybody so
man when your girlfriend left town or
when you left man it for me sometimes it
was so heartbreaking God so long
distance was real real tough I'd be
crying and [ __ ] but then as soon as I
got off the phone I'll be up to no good
looking for leg in that you know looking
for a little bitter that uh that low
mouth bro you know I'm saying that damn
whoo-whoo
you know that miscellaneous some you
know what I'm saying that salt that is
soft that damp wallet that damp body
wallet and that's cooter this episode is
brought to you by Bud elegance and if we
talk about body let's talk about bird
elegance but elegance is natural
cleansing foam brings you the luxury and
elegance of a bidet with the convenient
of toilet paper you can apply but
elegance moisturizing cleansing foam the
toilet paper in two wet clean and dry
your private areas both front and back
so you got that bat you
front shooter you got that front holster
whatever you got you can do it all with
but elegance clean up your plumbing
areas get tight get damp and then get
tight it's better than both dry and wet
toilet paper is better than wet wipes
you can control how much moisture is on
that hitter the Amazon review from a tpw
listener Marisa says five out of five
stars actual elegance this february
fourteenth twenty nineteen so obviously
was valentine's and she was trying to
shine up you know them body parts i
purchased his product due to theof on
recommending this to me on his podcast
at this past weekend he said if i
couldn't afford a bidet this would be
the next best option and i can't afford
a bidet well i currently rent my
residents and i don't think my landlord
or the HOA would be happy with me
installing one yeah you could always
hire one of them [ __ ] fancy lizards
off the internet to just spit water
right at you at your law at those low
tanks you know at that um at that over
at canal plus my bathroom is tiny and I
would not have anywhere to put it
unless I pulled out the shower maybe
anyway this ladies thing had too much
into it I think
but she says anyway I am cleaner than
ever thanks bud elegance and Theo von
and that's a real thing from Marissa and
I'm letting you know but elegance is
available right now on amazon.com for
ten percent off and free shipping use
promo code one zero Theo von all in in a
row that's ten percent off and free
shipping using the number one the number
zero Theo von or ten Theo von the number
ten Theo von at amazon.com
Bedell against stake couple more calls
happy Easter to you guys I hope your day
was beautiful you know hope you had some
peace I hope you were able to give an
extra hug to somebody you know sometimes
we don't realize the power of human
touch really and I'm saying somebody's
name you know one thing I liked it the
chair I went to the church service this
weekend and and the man said when you
say someone's name is different
you ever noticed that if your loved one
if you have a loved one
I'm boyfriend a girlfriend or something
or what you know one of the mixed crotch
bad boys you feel me can somebody got
that ginger snap that sugar lizard and
if somebody says you know a lot of times
your your significant other you talk to
him all the time you never say their
name you know and uh in this preacher
there's some sermon esteem is talking
about just the value in saying someone's
name and letting them know them
personally letting them know identifying
them as a actual person recognizing them
by their name and I noticed that when
somebody I care about her son says hey
Theo you know I feel this way or
somebody they had this do to my
neighborhood uh Thomas Wright and his
dude and this crazy family that like
saying liquor right Allah cker not like
the drip not like the booze and [ __ ]
with fun of that so amount I don't know
man
alright let's take another call dude the
hotline is nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three here we go
hey you my name is Sean first of all
thank you for calling is Sean home word
Happy Easter
everything world you I was calling
because it's been having some feelings a
lot lately you know I kind of grew up
for a long time in Hispanic culture in
the south you know my biological
father's Mexican well el dia de de los
el dia de los Domingos what is happy
Easter in Spanish let me see happy
Easter in Spanish Oh
Feliz Pasquale Philly's Basque was so
Philly's best cost to you my friend
homework now I've been moving around the
south doing a whole bunch of places and
being further and further taken away
from when a guy used to in that Hispanic
coach
over around Arizona and Texas and stuff
you know now I'm living North Carolina
that's just again a little bit different
and hard to try to connect I was
wondering if you have any sort of advice
on that seeing that you know you're good
Louisiana boy going over there to LA and
my cultural difference it is so
different you know how do you how do you
feel about having that big huge change
where you know down Louisiana you have
all that good old Southern culture and
going over to LA where you have just
about every other culture in the world
besides of the southern culture you know
just want to see your opinion on how
maybe you deal with those kinds of
differences well thank you for calling
mana and that's a nice question yeah I
think that cultural stuff is tough you
know I even realize it coming back this
weekend you know people some of the
things people say or behave the way they
are
I don't really judging I'm grateful
where I've come from
I'm grateful from the place that I'm
from and and I try to take a little bit
of that with me in LA but la isn't
really accepting like they say they're
accepting of a lot of things but they're
they're not accepting of a lot of or I
don't find in LA there's a ton of
acceptance for or right now maybe in the
summer could be just political climate
that even a southern accent everybody
immediately you know looks at you like
oh you're racist or you're in the area
IRRI ignorant you know you can't you
know you have to use a couple
calculators you got to call somebody if
there's math or something you know you
uh you don't do recipes because they
have math and them people think all that
kind of stuff you know that you probably
[ __ ] somebody that you know RIS you know
but your fan you know that's you
shouldn't be you know doing sex with and
stuff like that but I try to take you
know I try to take some of my heritage
with me I mean even down to my father
grew up in Nicaraguan you know moved
here when he was 12 into the United
States and and when I was young he would
always talk in Spanish and he
talk about Central America and he would
you know and and and once he passed away
they a lot of us stuff left my whole
universe so I just was in the South you
know just that white boy that poor white
treasure baby that's what I call myself
some poor white treasure baby and I was
you know and I just loved it I kind of
loved a little bit of the world I mean
there was a lot of stuff going on
there's a lot of you know [ __ ] sorry
a lot of southern culture you know the
food the vibe the you know the bigger
hugs and much deeper laughs here laughs
are a lot harder and then I got to LA in
a lot of that I felt honestly ashamed to
kind of I feel like I got judged because
of it and I wish I wouldn't have now I'm
just trying to be myself I'm just trying
to get closer and closer to being myself
and sometimes I don't even know who that
is but you know growing up like my
brother had darker skin you know my
brother has real olive skin and people
call him name people call him you know
uh [ __ ] people would call them sometimes
or and I'm not trying to use racial
slurs here but I'm just telling you I'm
not not going to tell you what happened
or they would call him a dark [ __ ]
sometimes people would say dark chain
and uh and so you know you [ __ ] I mean
I'm talking about dude how do I take my
heritage with me well it's always in me
it's always in me man I know no matter
what when I'm walking around in los
santos from a nice place and people are
being funny i know that i can hear just
as funny a conversation almost just
sitting around a plate of crawfish like
i did this weekend here in louisiana I
know that I did I realized heavily this
weekend that the stories you hear just
from anybody just sitting around have so
much better characters than half these
characters that get created out in
Hollywood in that world so I just you
know a lot of us just keep a little bit
of kind of a twinkle in my eye these
days where I just know that I have a
plethora of of gasoline in my tank that
other people that they can't
now some things they did you know do
change in me a little bit where I adapt
more to like healthier foods sometimes
or you know fit like physical fitness
you could I mean it's constant out in
and now lay there's always at places to
do any type of physical fitness so it's
like and I'll change a little bit but
I'll never let myself really change and
I think one thing you can look forward
to is there's a lot more Mexican culture
coming into the u.s. you know there's a
lot more in America so I think no matter
where you are more of it will catch up
with you over time and you can be a
beacon for that kind of thing you know
there's a lot of great similarities
between like the south and in an Mexican
culture you know there's like a lot of
religious similarities family is very
important a lot of great food a lot of
traditional recipes a lot of bad dancing
piece Dolas guns so I think uh I think
you're in a good spot man I think you're
in a good spot and don't be I would just
say don't be ashamed of it for a long
time I was ashamed to tell people that
my father's Nicaragua now I'm not
ashamed of that you know I'm just not
ashamed of it anymore because just
because some people maybe said stuff
when I was young that made me feel
ashamed of it like I'm grateful you know
I'm grateful for it now so I think you
sound like you're gonna be fine man just
keep your head up and and be a little
bit Mexican if you can't every now and
then you know put on that [ __ ]
sombrero and pull out that piece stole
our bra you know if I can take a donkey
to work dog you know what I'm saying if
I can live life baby and be that bad boy
and make fun of it have fun dude it's so
funny you get to be or if you want it to
be you could be a redneck second you can
make up a character that rednecks accan
and you know if that's not offensive I
don't really like to term redneck that
much but but uh but anyway dude I think
you got two great cultures stuck inside
of you so I don't know if there's a
problem at all I think it's might be
just a perspective
so gang gang brother you know what I'm
saying any gang brah I mean you could be
again you could do square dancing or
[ __ ] ms-13 bro you got it in you
let's take another call here here we go
what up Co this is Jordan sent out of
Owensboro Kentucky Gang Gang Owensboro
Kentucky man that's I've been over there
in Kentucky that's kind of a wild area
dude Owensboro I want to say and I'm not
judging man I won't say it's one of the
poorest places in America
Owens borough Kentucky I think uh anyway
yeah they just have a lot of poverty
there man so amen to you man for growing
up in those types of environments I know
it's really it can be tough sometimes
let's hear more home word I'm a lot of
time listener first-time Carly and you
know I mean I've been whooping a lot I
like to play best well I'm my spare time
Oh whooping okay I thought used to turn
my training dolphins or something or
training some of those jump and animals
homeward and I've come in a lot of uh I
come across a lot of racial
discrepancies in terms of like black
people coming at me sideways just
because of the color of my skin and like
I never I'm not racist I'm never one
that I diss that out but I was just
wondering like how do you think I should
to handle that situation when I'm being
like I'm fairly like discriminated
off the cover my skin as a white person
your honor me yeah I think you know you
handle it the way anybody can I mean I
mean these days I mean the biggest thing
is that people get a video and they
posted on a social media and they let
they let other people let that person
know that they're it's almost like
you're judged by like a jury not even
though your peers but just judged by my
humanity humanity lets you know what's
right or what's wrong and yeah man look
racism happens every way these days I
mean a mom like it happens every way and
a lot of times in the media they don't
like to say that but
really does and I think it happens less
overall and I think there's ways that it
happens that we don't even see it
happening you know ways that we judge or
ways that we look or experiences that we
had as a child where you look at
somebody now you're like damn bruh
you know I dude you might see a dude you
just you might see like you know you
might see a black guy late at night and
get scared you know or you might see a
[ __ ] white dude at the park with a
backpack on and a beard and you might
think he's gonna [ __ ] last year
somebody's just doing a frisbee golf you
know it's just you know there's all
types of sometimes we just have things
that are ingrained in us for maybe a
certain experience maybe you know that
kind of stuff but [ __ ] man you know I'm
talking about but I think it had all
that kind of stuff happens every ways
and I'll call people out about it man
you know I called the other day I called
um who do I call some guy was going off
about real real really off about Jewish
stuff and I like do you're a Jewish
supremacist man you're a Jewish
supremacist this guy was or somebody
that you know his arm could be a black
supremacist somebody could be a whi like
I don't think it's wrong for anybody
that wanted to support their own culture
there to to feel comfortable or navigate
within the worlds of their own skin tone
or their own voice their own you know
someone who has the same speaks the same
language some of those things are real
innate natural but yeah and I think it's
okay to joke around like if these people
are coming at you a little bit sideways
and they're joking with you then you
could be being too sensitive but yeah I
mean look people can be racist in every
direction how do you handle that I think
you just call them out you know call
them out in some places it's easier to
have those at conversations than in
other places you know but yeah I think
you blast them out man if somebody's
coming at you want to care what color
they are you are anything
or if they got a [ __ ] two legs and
you got no legs or whatever [ __ ] them if
they're coming at your heart you know
call them out dude or y'all so you could
go black body broth they're getting real
bad at you go black body you know I'm
saying show up at the core black body
and paint yourself chocolate from the
neck down and get on and [ __ ] drop 20
on him bro drop a triple-double son half
a can of sherwin-williams and daddys
[ __ ] hitting them tee dubs baby gang
but keep your head up over there in
Owensboro man I know life's not easy
sometimes an NA and and that's one of
the says here on the internet that's one
of the counties that has it really tough
sometimes so uh what else man I wanted
to get into some more things but I will
say Happy Easter felices bask wass happy
Paso that's how my Jewish friends I
realized a Passover they stay happy Paso
so if you had any of those things man
then I hope it was great and hope it was
a good time and what else dude that's
all man let's get through it I got to
edit this thing and put it up and and uh
and look Easter is a time for its new
things it's spring cleaning you know I
mean it's a it's a time to return as the
time to start over you know if you've
been doing something wrong you can let
it go and do it totally from a new place
you know that first caller this guy
called in a Theo von this is Dana think
we're calling amen he answered my phone
call on the podcast on Lutz Portland and
you wished the life has a new experience
for me then and it really has I
since then I've gotten my license back I
just got back into school I'm throwing a
fundraiser yeah that guy he's got his
birthday coming up and you know he's
having a new experience I might I don't
have anything to do with the fact that
he called this podcast friend like that
I'm not saying that I'm just saying it
expecting guys having a new experience
and I want some new experiences
sometimes you know I've been doing good
with the masty bro with that [ __ ] you
know that
that hand hockey brought at masturbation
and then I fell out week and a half ago
I fell out and died he was spraying out
and doing it all brah and dropping DNA
dude I knew it I could have drowned a
[ __ ] medium-sized bird with how much
I sprayed out but but now I'm back on
the track
I'm staying off the pornography and I'm
feeling good
and I'm just hoping to have a new
experience and and I know that I can I
know I can have a new experience you
know it's sometimes just risk y'all but
sometimes this I don't know dude I don't
even know man sorry I don't know if I
don't know what I'm talking about today
or it's just it's been kind of a long
week it's been a little long days a
little bit been a little bit of an
emotional day to you know just family
here and people getting older and you
know moan nieces and nephews getting
older and they don't you know some of
the games that they loved you know when
I saw him six months ago they don't even
remember they don't know about it
anymore and so I know this sounds kind
of lame but some of the envisions I have
in my head of us you know spending time
together doing something they're not
even into those things anymore they
don't give a fair so I don't know I
guess I'd to some like little
expectations of things we would be able
to do for fun and and they don't like to
do those things so they don't even care
about hanging out with me anymore you
know in certain moments and instances or
so it's I don't know feel sad out again
bummed out that you know little kids
don't think I'm neat or whatever they
don't but [ __ ] whatever man it's not
a big thing but it's just you know it's
just life you go and or you go visit a
family member and you have ideas in your
head I was going to be like this can be
like that and then they're real busy or
they have something going on you didn't
expect or you know if somebody got sick
or somebody cancelled so they couldn't
come it's just uh it's life is all it is
this life but in the end at the end of
the day I yeah I think is
it's the best thing going happy Easter
to you and you guys be good to
yourselves I know that you deserve it
and uh and I'm happy to be here with you
today
gang gang baby
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that music is still pretty bad man
happy sure you guys I love you I'll see
you this weekend in West Palm Beach and
then the following weekend in New York
and some new tour dates should be coming
out I think next week we'll have some
new cities that were dropping and I'm
grateful I hope you're able to find some
things you're grateful for you know find
some gratitude and because those things
always help power me you know when I'm
really able to feel grateful for
something that's going on it just makes
it just makes the rest of my life
lighter you know if I'm gonna put lemon
up if my brain is gonna work so hard to
stack so many things on the side of the
scale to weigh me down it should it
should I should give a little I should
give equal amount of time to wait so
putting some things on the side of the
scale to lighten me up and it's usually
gratitude that does that for me but I'm
not talking at you I'm kind of just
trying to remind myself as well but be
good to yourselves man I know you
deserve it gang
you